Now, let's move on to
overloading operations.
Here at the top, I've defined a struct
called TeamRecord that records
the number of wins and
losses for a team.
We'll just assume this struct is
describing the wins and losses for
a team playing American football,
that's in season right now.
Now, it would be convenient if we
could add two team records together
like we would any other basic type.
And that's what I'm trying to do here,
but
unless we write a function that
describes how two team records could be
added together the swif compiler won't
be able to perform this operation.
So, to define addition we'll start
with funk and the the plus symbol.
Then addition takes two arguments.
An argument that goes on the left
side of the addition sign, and
an argument that goes on the right side.
Both of the arguments
should be team records, and
we want to return a new team record
after performing what we described
as the edition of two team records.
So, for team records, we just want to
add the numbers of wins together, and
the number of losses together.
We can do this in one line, by returning
a new instance of team record, and
adding the wins and
losses from the left and right side.
In line right here.
Now, our addition works
just like a charm.
It takes the records for 2013 and 2014,
it adds the wins together and
it adds the losses together.
You can see that outputted here.
You may be asking yourself if I
had to define the addition for
team records, does that addition is
defined for Int, strings, floats,
and other basic types too.
Well, that's a great question,
and you're right they are.
So, when you think about it, when we
defined addition here for Team Records,
we were actually overloading
the addition operator to work for
a new type, in this case, Team Record.
So, we could in fact redefine
how addition works for any type,
like the basic type ints.
I'm going to go ahead and
do that now for demonstration purposes,
but this would be a terrible
idea in real code.
You can see now that the addition of
two ints gives up some really strange
results and again,
this is a really, really bad idea.
Do not do this in practice.
I'm going to go ahead and
get rid of this for
now just so
I don't have someone yell at me later.